GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THIS IS OUR LAST DAY IN KYOTO
JAPAN.
WE ARE HEATING IN
WE ARE HEADING IN AN INTERVIEW
WITH THE PRESIDENT AFTER THE
SHOW AND WE'LL BRING IT TO YOU
MONDAY.
LAST NIGHT HAD A PRIMARY
DEBATE AND WHAT PASSES FOR THE
HEAVY HITTERS ON THE LEFT IN
ATTENDANCE.
JOE BIDEN, PETE BUTTIGIEG,
KAMALA HARRIS AND BERNIE
SANDERS.
ON IMMIGRATION, AT LEAST, THEY
SEEMED IN TOTAL AGREEMENT.
[CHANTING]
SORRY FOR THE TAPE MIXUP.
THAT WAS THE YOUTH WING MAKING
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME POINT.
WATCH PETE BUTTIGIEG.
THIS IS THE RIGHT TAPE.
BUTTIGIEG IS A MAYOR AND A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE BUT A
SELF-DESCRIBED MORAL LEADER
GANDI OR JACKSON BROWN.
WATCH HIM SAY IT'S MORALLY
WRONG TO MAINTAIN
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS.
>> THE CRIMINALIZATION IS THE
BASIS FOR FAMILY SEPARATION.
YOU DO AWAY WITH THAT, IT'S NO
LONGER POSSIBLE.
OF COURSE, IT WOULDN'T BE
POSSIBLE ANYWAY IN MY
PRESIDENCY BECAUSE IT IS DEAD
WRONG.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
SNEAKING IN SOMEONE ELSE'S
COUNTRY CAN NEVER BE A CRIME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE A
SPY, GANG MEMBER, DRUG MULE
WITH 20 KILOS OF HEROIN ON
YOUR BACK OR A HUMAN
TRAFFICKER WITH STABLE OF
CHILD PROSTITUTES.
YOU ARE WELCOME HERE.
WE WON'T JUDGE YOU.
IN FACT WE'LL GLADLY PAY FOR
YOUR COMPREHENSIVE MEDICAL
CARE NO MATTER WHAT IT TAKES.
THAT'S HOW MUCH WE RAISE
OURSELVES.
WATCH.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT PLAN WOULD PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: GOT THAT, MR. AND
MRS. AMERICAN?
YOU MAY BE GOING BROKE TRYING
TO PAY FOR YOUR OWN FAMILY'S
HEALTHCARE, MANY OF YOU ARE,
BY THE WAY.
BUT NOW YOU GET TO PAY FOR
FREE HEALTHCARE FOR THE REST
OF THE WHOLE WORLD.
ANYONE WHO IGNORES OUR LAWS
AND SNEAKS IN, YOU OWE THEM
BENEFITS THE SECOND THEY GET
HERE.
GOT THAT, RACIST?
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, TOUGH.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY PLANS TO
DISARM YOU SO YOU ARE
POWERLESS.
CONGRESSMAN STALLWALL CALLED
FOR THIS.
>> I'M THE CANDIDATE ASKING
FOR BUY-BACK PROGRAM OF ARMS.
>> Tucker: DOESN'T YOUR
CONSTITUTION GUARANTEE YOUR
RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS?
THE DOCUMENT SAYS THAT.
BUT ONCE THAT BERNIE SANDERS
MOVES THE CONSERVATIVE OFF THE
SUPREME COURT, THE LEFT CAN DO
WHATEVER IT WANTS.
WATCH HIM EXPLAIN.
>> I DO NOT BELIEVE IN PACKING
THE COURT.
WE HAVE A TERRIBLE 5-4
MAJORITY, CONSERVATIVE COURT
RIGHT NOW.
I DO BELIEVE CONSTITUTIONALLY
WE CAN ROTATE JUDGES TO OTHER
COURTS AND THAT WOULD BRING IN
NEW BLOOD TO THE SUPREME
COURT.
>> Tucker: BERNIE SANDERS
TALKING ABOUT NEW BLOOD.
IT'S ALL SO GREAT.
KEEP IN MIND THAT IS NOT
COURT-PACKING.
NO, NOT EVEN CLOSE.
IT'S COURT-ROTATING.
THAT MEANS GETTING RID OF
JUDGES THAT BERNIE SANDERS
DOESN'T LIKE AND INSTALLING
JUDGES WHO AGREE WITH BERNIE
SANDERS.
THAT IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
THE OTHER CANDIDATES SEEMED ON
BOARD WITH THAT.
OR THEY WERE TOO BUSY
ATTACKING JOE BIDEN TO NOTICE
WHAT THE OLD GUY ON.
THERE IS A LOT TO HIT BIDEN
ON.
HIS SEX, COLOR OF HIS SKIN.
BUT STALLWELL POINTED OUT THAT
JOE BIDEN IS REALLY, REALLY
OLD.
>> I WAS 6 YEARS OLD WHEN A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE CAME TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION AND SAID IT'S TIME
TO PASS THE TORCH TO A NEW
GENERATION OF AMERICANS.
THAT CANDIDATE WAS THEN
SENATOR JOE BIDEN.
BIDEN WAS RIGHT WHEN HE SAID
IT WAS TIME TO PASS THE TORCH
TO THE NEW GENERATION OF
AMERICANS.
HE IS STILL RIGHT TODAY.
IF WE SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
AUTOMATION, PASS THE TORCH.
IF HE SOLVE THE ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHAOS, PASS THE TORCH.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT, OLD
MAN?
JOE BIDEN IS A MUSTY ANTIQUE
WHO OUGHT TO BE EATING SOFT
FOOD IN FLORIDA SOMEWHERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE?
HE IS A RACIST.
A BITTERLY ELDERLY BIGOT.
HE'S PROBABLY WATCHING "BIRTH
OF THE NATION" AND KAMALA
HARRIS MADE THAT CLEAR.
HE STARTED OUT SAYING HE IS
NOT A RACIST MEANING HE IS
DEFINITELY A RACIST.
>> I WILL DIRECT THIS TO VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I DO NOT BELIEVE YOU ARE A
RACIST.
BUT YOU ALSO WORKED WITH THEM
TO OPPOSE BUSING.
THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
SHE WAS BUSED TO SCHOOL EVERY
DAY.
THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING ABOUT
THAT IS FAKE.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE MORE
DISINGENUOUS PARAGRAPH.
KAMALA HARRIS IMPLIES
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WERE
SEGREGATED IN THE 1970s.
THEY WERE NOT.
SOME OF US WERE THERE.
HARRIS WAS NOT A CIVIL RIGHTS
HERO.
HER FATHER WAS LITERALLY A
STANFORD ECONOMICS PROFESSOR
AND SHE WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL IN
MONTRE
MONTRÉAL, CANADA.
A CHILD OF PRIVILEGE IF THERE
EVER WAS ONE.
AS FOR FORCED BUSING, IT'S
AMAZING THAT ANY DEMOCRAT
WOULD DEFEND IT.
BUSING DIDN'T WORK.
IT WAS AN ABJECT FAILURE.
BLACK FAMILIES HATED IT.
IT DIDN'T RAISE ANYBODY'S
SCORES IN THE END.
BUSING DIDN'T WORK.
HONEST PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
ADMIT THAT.
BROOKINGS ADMITTED THAT.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO LIKED
BUSING THEN AND NOW ARE RICH
LIBERALS, THE ONES THAT ARE
TOTALLY INSULATED FROM THE
EFFECTS OF THE FAIL AND THE
STUPID SOCIAL POLICY.
EVERYONE ELSE IN THIS COUNTRY,
90% OF AMERICANS ACCORDING TO
GALLOP THOUGHT BUSING WAS
AWFUL.
GOOD CALL.
RUN ON THAT.
MORE BUSING!
JOE BIDEN IS A RACIST.
HERE IS OUR NOMINEE, KAMALA
HARRIS.
LISTEN TO HER EXPLAIN WHY SHE